- [Voiceover] We're now
in 1944 and the things
are really starting to close
in on the Axis powers now.
We can start in January.
You might remember, you've
had the Siege of Leningrad
going on for several years now.
Incredibly bloody siege,
incredibly hard on the
civilians of Leningrad.
But the Soviet army is
finally able to end that,
and so you see from these
troop movements on this map
starting in January of 1944
with the end of the siege,
they are able to really take the offensive
and start marching through the Baltics,
through the Baltic states.
At the same time, you have
the Soviet armies marching
and they're able to force
the Axis to surrender
in the Crimea.
You fast forward further into
the year, further into 1944.
You might remember in
1943, the Allies were able
to land on Italy and force
the surrender of Italy
to the Allied powers.
But that doesn't mean that
Italy, as we know it today,
or even as we knew it then,
was free of the German troops,
or from the Axis troops.
And so, the Allies were
continuing to slog through,
slog through Italy,
and in particular Rome.
Rome did not get liberated in 1943.
The Allies had to continue bombing Rome.
And it doesn't get liberated
until June of 1944.
So Rome is liberated.
So liberated in the summer of 1944.
That happens June, 5th.
The next day, and this is
probably one of the most
famous events in World War II,
especially from an American point of view,
something that's documented in many films,
is June, 6th, D-Day, 1944.
You have the invasion of Normandy,
the amphibious invasion of Normandy,
probably most famously
depicted in the opening scenes
of Saving Private Ryan.
We have British, primarily
British and American troops.
They are able to storm the
beaches of Normandy successfully
which allows them to start making progress
in northern France towards Germany.
Now, also in the summer of 1944,
rockets start to get
involved in a serious way
in World War II.
The Germans are starting
to send their V1 rockets
over to Great Britain.
And the V1 rockets,
this is just significant
from the history of technology.
Obviously today rockets play a big deal
in a whole bunch of context,
and this was the first time
that they were deployed
in a major way during a war.
The first V1 rockets, they
weren't all that impressive,
they traveled three or four
hundred miles per hour,
slower than modern jet-liners.
They didn't travel at
that high of an altitude.
But as we'll see, or as
we'll see even in this video,
within a few months, by September,
they were sending in V2 rockets,
which were far more advanced,
going several thousand miles per hour,
getting to altitudes
of tens of miles high,
and carrying even larger payloads.
So the Germans were really
starting to push the envelope
in terms of rocket science.
What's good about the Allie
is, is that the Germans
were kind, they developed this
technology a little bit late.
They are starting to be
on the heels, obviously,
on both the Western front
and the Eastern front,
and even in the South the Allies
were really on the offensive now,
but rockets are starting to get involved.
V1's in the summer, and
then the V2's in the fall.
Now, also as we go into
the late summer and fall,
you see that Russians, after
defeating the Germans at Kursk,
are marching towards,
are marching towards Poland,
and marching in particular towards Warsaw,
as we go through 1944.
And at the end of 1944,
not the end really,
at the end of the summer of 1944,
in August of 1944,
you have the Polish uprising,
you have kind of the rebels.
The underground is taking
on the German occupiers.
So this is August, 1944.
August, 1944.
With the Russian troops,
or the Soviet troops
not that far away, they're
getting closer and closer
and closer to Warsaw.
Now, also in August of 1944,
you have Paris, is liberated.
So this is August, 25th, 1944.
Paris is liberated.
And then, as we go later into that year,
British troops are able
to liberate Athens.
So British troops are
able to liberate Athens.
So Athens is liberated.
And actually this, once this liberated,
then you start having the
beginnings of the Civil War,
of the Greek Civil War that occurs
between kind of the government
troops and the Communists,
or as you say the more left-leaning people
who were involved in fighting
against the Axis powers.
So, even though they were liberated,
it's kind of the start of
another unfortunate chapter
with the Greek Civil War.
And then, finishing out
1944, the Axis powers,
and particularly the Germans,
they weren't done yet.
Even though the war is not looking good,
they finally mount a,
I guess you could say
one of their last counteroffensive,
just not their last
major counteroffensive.
And that's over here
against the Allied troops,
particularly the American troops,
at the Battle of the Bulge.
And this starts in December of 1944.
It's called the Battle of the Bulge
because the shape in
which, so if the Allied,
you know, the front, the
Allied front looks like that
as it is advancing.
The Germans mount a counteroffensive
and they are able to create a,
what's called in military terms a salient,
where they're able to push through,
where they're able to push through
and kind of create, and create this bulge.
This is an incredibly bloody battle,
it's actually the most bloody battle
faced by American troops.
They lose nearly 20
thousand, not just lose,
20 thousand die, American troops die
just in the Battle of the Bulge
that starts in December of 1944.
But this really is the
Germans last hurrah.
You can see they're riding on the wall,
troops approaching from the West,
troops approaching from the East,
troops approaching from the South.